all righty sup y'all it's your boy rhino raider running the pod solo this week
and when i'm solo you know what we do we get in those technical nitty-gritty details
um so i actually know what i'm going to call this episode already i'm going to call it the saml ramble
because i'm about to ramble for the next you know however many minutes about saml to you guys and
try to pique your interest in saml um it's kind of a complicated topic so um the goal for this
episode is going to get you interested in it and get you comfortable enough with the structure of
saml where you can desire to attack it where you'll be curious and not scared by it whenever
you see it in an sso context okay so that's the that's the goal now um i chose saml because i'm
really interested in it and uh the reason i'm really interested in it is this saml is everywhere
we see it in a lot of organizations being used uh for single sign-on and for idp um your identity
provider uh services and here's the crazy part okay it's xml based and which we all know all the
concerns that go around with xml but it just kind of recently struck me that if a if a company is using
saml for their identity you know in conjunction with their identity provider then all of the
different applications that they're going to be um logging into using this single sign-on
will need to be parsing xml and parsing saml right um and because it's such a complicated thing
uh you know all of these different languages you've got java apps you've got node apps you've got python
apps all of these are going to have different libraries that they're using to parse the saml
uh the saml assertions or the saml responses and um i'm sure that there will be uh you know some some
quirks between all of these different applications right so whenever i i feel like whenever i see saml
it's like oh there's got to be a bug on the scope somewhere because not all of these things can be
parsing it exactly the same way okay so rant over there um lots of attack potential uh for saml so
let's let's get ourselves comfortable with it because i don't know about y'all but before um before i did
this deep dive on saml and prep for this episode i was a little intimidated by saml because um you
know you see this giant base64 blob and then you base64 decode it and then xml inflated so you're
actually looking at the xml and then it's just a huge you know blob of xml and there's all sorts of
like references to what is it w3.org or something like that where it's like check out this protocol and
and that sort of thing and the schema and there's all sorts of attributes and you know who knows what
all of it does um and and sometimes even there's like large base64 encoded blobs inside of the saml
response you know encapsulating certificates and signatures and it's just like gets overwhelming
really quickly at least that was the experience that i had before i deep dived it for this episode
so i'm hoping that we can delete that and get us comfortable with it okay so the thing that spurred this
research was um a researcher that i'm really a big fan of named green dog released uh some of the
details that they did on a talk in at a conference called kazakhstan which is awesome that's such a
great name for a conference and i mentioned it on the pod a couple weeks ago and it's called how to
break saml if i have pause okay so i was looking through this this presentation and i was kind of
looking at all the various techniques in there and that is an amazing presentation that we will link
uh you know below so definitely go check that out because this is going to require a little bit
extra research on your behalf to become really really you know on top of of saml stuff um because
there's only so much you can do over a podcast um and sometimes you just need to see stuff so uh
there's going to be a lot of resources associated with this episode that you'll need to go and check
out um so i was reading through this this slide deck by by green dog also check out his weird proxy
stuff because that's the name of the repo weird proxies uh that's a that's really interesting
research um and i and i i stumbled upon this just absolute gem of an article by a researcher named epi
052 uh which is the same guy that did ferrox buster by the way um on how to hunt bugs in saml a methodology
and this was from 2019 research from 2019 and holy moly is it good um there's three parts they're they're
you know very digestible very readable very simply written clearly this guy knows what's up with with
saml because you know when you can take it and you can make it this simple it rocks so my my plan for
the rest of the day rest of the day rest of this episode is to is to talk to you guys about the
methodology that he lays out in that in that um uh blog series that he does and uh just kind of
generally get us familiar with that so let's go ahead and go down that path so before before we
get into the attack factor stuff we've got to understand a little bit about uh saml or uh security
assertion markup language okay so here's the here's the basic context in in which uh this is used
okay so you've got a user all right we gotta we gotta add some terms out of the way here first
we've got um a user that's the person that's wanting to off into an application or a service
provider okay an application you know let's say you wanted to off into you know an organization's
uh let's just say it's their git lab or something like that right that would be a service provider
sp service provider um hopefully these terms will not make this more complicated uh or scare away any
of you so just when you hear service provider think app okay and then we've also got the identity
provider okay that's the person that's providing the identity that's going to be your you know sort of sso
domain right your your sso service provider okay whoa i can't say sso service provider your sso
portal let's just say that okay and they're the ones you log into that and then it throws your
auth over to your service provider your app okay so we've got the service provider that's the app
identity provider that's the sso domain okay so the basic flow that happens is this the user wants to
off into the service provider they want to off into the app so the service provider says okay sure i'm
going to create this parameter called saml request that contains a base 64 encoded xml
document essentially and they're going to redirect us uh via our browser uh over to the identity
provider okay the identity provider is going to look at that saml request uh look at the xml inside of
it and it's going to say okay i understand you know i need to off this user for whatever service provider
uh now i need to off this user so then we go ahead and we put our credentials in to the service
provider excuse me we put our credentials into the identity provider and then it will go ahead and
create something called a saml response okay the saml response uh will contain a cryptographically signed
saml response tag that contains assertions about who the user is so they're asserting hey this user
is bloody blah right you can trust that okay and so that saml response is put into a a a parameter in http
it could be a query parameter it could be a post post body um and then sends it back over to the service
provider or the app okay um and the app will then look at that saml response parse it and trust uh
cryptographically hopefully cryptographically check um that that similar response is is valid not
tampered with and then trust the person that the identity provider said is there and log them into
that account okay so it's a pretty standard flow when you look at sso um based applications so that's
the that's the the basic flow let me i'm gonna take a sip of water now
all righty so um let's let's break it down a little bit further and we'll start talking about attack
factors okay um so before we get any any into the technical details of what the xml structure looks
like i just want to say that i've noticed a pretty strong correlation between libraries and domains that
use saml and xss okay so i i don't know why that is uh maybe it's an older technology but um whenever
you see an application parsing saml or a sso domain that is is utilizing saml to log users in
um then you're going to want to check that pretty thoroughly for xss you're going to want to check that
for xss in the um in the saml request so that first little um information that is sent from the service
provider the app to the identity provider or the sso domain right and you're going to want to inject
xss related payloads in there and and i'll give you an example of this later and see if they fire
on the identity provider or see if they fire on the service provider via the saml response so if you're
injecting inside of tags in the saml response or you're injecting in and attributes in the saml response
and sometimes it'll throw an error be like hey this is an invalid thing here's the invalid thing and
then they embed embed the invalid thing in the dom and then it triggers xss so it's a story you guys
are all familiar with i'm not going to explain how xss works here but um just know that there is a
pretty strong correlation with saml and xss okay and then the only other caveat i'll add to that is that
in order to embed xss payloads inside of attributes and inside of tags you may need to html encode those
brackets normally html encoding is our enemy in these scenarios right if you see it html encoded that's bad
but in order for it to not break it and for it to parse properly we have to html encode it sometimes
and then it will get re-injected back into the dom um html decoded and in its full you know xss glory so
that that's that i'll leave that there um definitely look at saml related stuff for xss okay so now let's go and talk about
attacks um outlined by uh epio 52 and what kind of uh in attacks that are a little bit more relevant to
saml uh itself okay so the first attack that that epio 52 has in their description is test whether or
not the sp accepts an assertion without a signature okay this is known as signature exclusion okay so
as i mentioned before the saml response the thing that is coming back from the identity provider and
going to the um service provider uh that response is a xml document and uh there are a couple things
that are normally inside this document for one there is a saml response uh tag that that tag contains
almost everything else that that'll that you'll need inside of it okay um it also contains a lot of
signatures okay signatures okay signatures are the things that uh cryptographically ensure the integrity
of the saml response okay um and so when we talk about uh an sp accepting an assertion without a
signature that will be um you know us simply just removing the signature tags from the saml uh the saml
document okay so all you have to do is base 60 40 code xml inflate um and then take out the signatures
re re-encode it up and send it over to the sp and if they accept it boom you're in because you can just
modify that assertion to have to have um anything you want in it well how do you modify an assertion well
an assertion is exactly kind of what it sounds like it's asserting that the idp or the idp the um identity
provider is asserting that the user is a specific person so a lot of times this will contain attributes
saying uh which is another tag inside of a saml um saying something along the lines of like uh user dot
you know username or whatever is rhino reader right and and it'll have a bunch of attributes that the
identity provider wants to convey to the service provider okay so if we could modify those assertions
uh and those attributes within the assertions then uh we're golden right because um we can just assert
that we're anybody uh and the only way that those assertions are actually validated for integrity is via
the signature so if we just remove the signature and send it on through then we're we're great and
there's a report that we'll cover later on in this episode that where this exactly this sort of
vulnerability happens so um this is an easy attack vector you can try however um you don't always
have access when you're trying to hack a company you don't always have access to a sample uh saml response
right excuse me um so you may need to take sort of a template saml response and just google you know
saml response template and send it on through and see what it says because sometimes it'll say uh hey
you're missing this attribute and sometimes it'll say hey there's no signature here what the heck is going
on right um and so in in the scenarios where it says hey you're missing this attribute there's a very
good chance that it's actually not checking the signature and it's just gonna uh you know tell
you what kind of attributes you need in order to log in any account that you want so definitely try to
be going after um assertions without a signature uh when you see any saml related um endpoints okay
um the next the next section that we want to talk about is uh xml signature wrapping okay and and
before we get into this section i'll throw a caveat out here okay um there's a burp extension called saml
raider okay this extension is super fire and uh epio 52 talks about it in the um the blog post and gives
a very clear example on how to execute all of these attacks um using saml raider uh very simply uh so
if you're using if you're using burp definitely check that out if you're not using burp uh you
might can open burp for this specific thing because uh it's it's pretty awesome and i don't believe
it's a pro extension so anyone should be able to use it with the community edition
um okay so let's talk about uh xml signature wrapping in order to actually understand this
vulnerability from a technical perspective we have to understand a little bit about signatures okay
um so as we mentioned before signature the signature tag inside of the saml response
is the thing that uh gives you gives us cryptographic security when when using saml okay so there's a
couple tags uh inside of the saml tag that we need to be aware of there's the signed info tag there's the
signature value there's key info and object okay um the the most important one here is signed info and
that signed info also has a sub tag called the reference tag okay and that reference tag is going
to contain a uri attribute just like this is just like html right like you have an href attribute for
an for an a tag right um we have a uri attribute for this reference tag and this is going to provide an id
of the assertion or the um other tag could be a response could be an assertion that uh it is signing for
a signature okay uh so you know let's say you've got a response that has id123 and then somewhere
you've got a signature that has a reference with uri equals one two three that signature is correlated
to that response okay so you just compare the ids and you're good to go um and these signatures can
live in multiple places throughout the xml document okay there's three that you need to really be aware of
there can be an enveloped signature which is the signature inside of the response right so you've got
response tag and then you've got signature tag um and then you've got end signature tag and response
tag right um so that would be an enveloped signature because the signature is inside of the response or
the thing that it's signing for then you've also got an enveloping signature right an enveloping
signature and that is the signature surrounds the response in this scenario we've got the signature
tag we've got the signed info tag and then we've got the end signed info tag we've got the response
tag end response tag signature right so it goes signature signed info response and signature right
and so the the response tag is inside of the um signature tag itself and we still have the reference
ids as mentioned before that are correlating um the ids of the response tag with the uh reference id
inside of the signed info section of the signature so you know you should be able to correlate them
finally the last one we've got is the detached signature okay and this is outside of the response
or the assertion or whatever it's signing so let's say for example you've got saml uh saml response right
and then you've got closed saml response signature and then close signature right so it's just totally
disjointed from the thing that it's signing okay and because of these different ways that you can
put this signature there's like a whole mess i want to say let me let me pull up the article right here
there's i think there's eight yeah there's eight different attacks you can do where you're like
you know having a specific response that has a detached signature but that detached signature also has
a you know uh an assertion inside of it and and like you're just putting all of these different
assertions in different spots and you're putting um you know data inside of it in a in a um in an
enveloping signature that is not correlated at all to this signature and hope that it will get accepted
blindly um and so there's lots of different techniques that you can use here to try to sneak assertions
uh and responses into this this saml response okay and get it parsed by and accepted by the service provider
um and like i said before a simul raider will largely take care of all this for you um and there's
i mean literally uh each one of the i don't want to sit here and read all of them to you because it's
just going to be too dull for a podcast but i mean each one of these attacks has a beautiful graph on it
um and and will and has like three sentences associated with it just explaining what it does right so
that really really simple when you've got the the graphics um so definitely check out part two of
epio 52 saml testing methodology if you actually want to understand this stuff a little bit better
but by simply inserting assertions into various spots throughout the saml document you may be able to
sneak some values in there which could really affect the way that the service provider parses the
saml document and maybe even get you a full auth bypass which would be super awesome um so that's
that's the uh xml signature wrapping section the next one on epio 52's list is test whether or not
the sp verifies that the assertion came from a trusted idp okay so is the app verifying that the
assertion is coming from a trusted uh identity provider right um and so the way that this would be
um executed normally is by including a public key that the sp should use to validate the the signature
inside of the signature in the key info section okay um so this is also something you can see in more
detail on the write-up but um just sort of conceptually you're sending that x5 x509 certificate
along with the saml response um and that will then get parsed by the sp and used to validate the the
signature on the thing it's like kind of stupid like why would you use the certificate of the thing
you're trying to validate to validate it like that doesn't make any sense um but it does happen so
that's called the certificate faking vulnerability in saml and um and so that's something we should be
on the lookout for and like i said you know maybe this isn't going to be vulnerable to one of the
applications a company uses um you know in their in their infrastructure but if they're using saml over
the whole organization then some application has got to be vulnerable to something right so um really good
attack surface uh to deep dive here i think um all right so the next one that he's got on his list is
like test whether or not the sp creates more than a single session per assertion okay so maybe you like
take the sp response you send it multiple times if you get two unique sessions then you know it's a
replay attack uh you know this one i just kind of skipped over because it's like this isn't really a bug
um but it could be indicative of uh other problems with their saml parsing so you know maybe poke around at it
okay next one is test whether or not the sp is vulnerable to xxe now this is the one that i've
been doing for years right whenever i see saml i'm like all right you know what saml justin's brain goes
okay saml that's xml right uh well xml is vulnerable to xxc so let's just try that um and that's pretty
much the extent of the saml testing i did for a long time um and i found several xxs with this so
definitely do this not trying to discount the technique at all but um you know go and essentially
to exploit this you just have to base64 decode xml inflate the um the uh saml response and then
insert the xxc payload go ahead and re-encode it with saml saml deflation and then base64 encode it
um and then send it over to the sp and if they accept it and it pops then great and i'm not going
to go ahead and explain all the different ways that you could test xxc because um you know there's
lots of ways that you could do that uh but i'm going to leave that as an exercise to you guys um
we will i will say here we will talk about a little bit later in this episode about something called
transforms or transformations um which will modify the xml document uh when it's being
parsed by the service provider and there is a really cool bug that i'll that will link to the description
um uh of course it's project zero because those guys are total badasses and uh they found a way to
like use transforms to get past the uh entity um xml entity being disabled on on a library and it was
actually only like last year in 2022 so actually this is something that could be really applicable to
lots of bug bounty programs still if they're not patching um so definitely check that out um all right so
check for xxc and i will add as well you may want to check for xxc on the service provider side and on
the idp side right because the idp is also you know if it's like one login or like you know uh some of
these other well-known sso providers then you know well i should i shouldn't say that you shouldn't test
those because you definitely should uh and they most of them do have bug bounty programs but you know
once you've tested it you you may not have to test it every single time you see it um but if it's some
janky sso provider then you may want to just try it there too so you can try it on the service
provider side and on the identity provider side for xxc okay um the next one on the list is actually
test whether or not the sp is vulnerable to ssrf via certificate okay and i'm actually i'm gonna go
ahead and look at the blog post really quickly here uh yeah okay so this one actually is not in
um fb052's um uh write up this is actually an addition that i did to to this list um thanks to
to green dogs um write up and essentially in his uh in slides he talks about certificate validation to ssrf
okay and this is something that i just think is really cool and something that i've i've tried recently
with um with a couple programs that i have been working on that accept x5 and un certificates as input
from the user um and essentially it's some research that came out in black hat of 2023 so just a couple
months ago that uh and it was released by a guy named uh michael stepankin and uh there's just a
couple fields inside of an x509 certificate specifically the extensions of the x509 certificate um that
could actually cause ssrf when the certificate is being parsed okay so specifically there's a uh
extension called the authority information access extension i'll actually just i'll just go ahead
and read it right here um for instance the authority information access extension contains a url pointing
to the issuer certificate if this extension is used for validation there's a high chance that you can
exploit it to perform an ssrf attack okay so there's a field inside of this um you know extension
uh that you can put a url in and when it's validating that certificate and and maybe the certificate
chain associated with it then it might reach out to that url to grab the issuer's certificate right
um and so that could result in ssrf and likely it would be blind ssrf but uh blindness is better than
no ssrf and blindness rf can often be well i shouldn't say often can sometimes be turned into full read ssrf
depending on the amount of error logging that is in place so definitely keep that technique in mind
um i think there's a decent amount of attack surface uh that i've seen recently um by doing weird stuff
with x509 certificates like um you can craft a certificate i'm getting a little bit off topic
now but you can craft a certificate that has some um cryptographic problems with it right and when
they try to uh use it it will you know use up a whole mess of memory um so i'll see if i can find
that article and put it in the description as well but uh definitely be on the lookout for x509 parsing
problems because i think that is something that we'll see uh grow over the next couple years okay
next one is test whether or not the sp is vulnerable to xslt that's extensible style sheet
language transformation uh via saml and to be honest in my saml deep dive that i did this is the most
like mind-blowing thing that i found because i'd heard of this before actually at one of my first live
hacking events um some legend i think it was sam herb of course because this is such a like sam herb thing
um used this to like hack some xml related thing right uh it might have even been saml um but
uh you know this isn't something that i had thought about for years um and and here it is and it's
so much easier than excuse me it's so much easier than i thought um this is pretty much very much like
a a xxc okay um the the language at xslt is extremely flexible uh there's so much you can do with it
um and it's actually if i remember correctly from the notes i think it's a turing complete language
so you can write i mean you can write a lot of code in here um and you can do stuff like just read files
and then xfiltrate them to the attacker server just like an xxe and actually might even be more powerful
than an xxe in that capacity um so definitely something cool to look into here um so let me tell
you a little bit about how it works um i mentioned transformations before i'll read a quick
true uh quote about transformations uh so you can understand what kind of role they play in saml okay
so it says transformations are a very powerful tool to transform saml user attribute values transmitted
through the saml response all right so that's the thing coming back from the idp to the sp right to
the app um transmitted through the saml response or assertions from the identity provider mainly they
are used to transform not changeable values within the identity provider so the transformed value fits
the uh the required or desired attribute format in the application okay so good old you know identity
provider doesn't want to change service provider doesn't want to change stuff right here right you
know there has to be this whole language that we've created just to like make the names line up so that
people don't have to actually modify their code um and that's what that's what this is uh and so
essentially how it works is you can add a a transform tag uh inside of your inside of your signature
um which will be parsed uh parsed before the signature is actually validated okay this is the
kind of this is the crazy thing um let me see if i can find this other quote here um yeah the reason for
this is that the xslt transformation occurs before the digital signature is processed right so this
should really be like setting off fire alarms in your head right now right there is something
there's a token that is being taken and used for authentication and there is a whole you know turing
complete language that you may be able to use uh in this the parsing of this token which uh gets
processed before the cryptographic signature gets processed right that i mean i can
feel my i can feel my pulse rising right now just just talking about it right um so very cool stuff
here and something that we should definitely be looking at anytime we see saml um because you know
even signature validation isn't going to stop us here because it gets parsed before signatures get
validated so uh very cool so essentially you know i've got a payload here right in front of me and i'd
like to just sort of read it out to you but it's going to be kind of hard to process so
essentially i'll tell you how it goes um inside of this transform tag you know you define that
there's going to be a um a style sheet that is and you reference the w3.org transform um spec okay so
it knows what what this is and then inside of that you have this um template that you define uh that applies
to specific um uh xml tags you can say all right i only want this to affect whatever tag you know the if this
is html you could say all right i just wanted to affect the h1 tag or whatever right and then you
can define a whole set of things to do to that tag and uh from looking at right here from the example
that is in uh epio52's write-up um he essentially just says okay uh assign a variable file to the value
for etsy password go ahead and uri encode that file you can see the power of this language right here right
go ahead it has you know a function for encode to uri um and then uh concatenate it with the attacker url
and then go get that url right um and so it's like this is such a powerful language that i didn't know
existed uh so so it really blew my mind when i started learning about it i will add one caveat here and
i'm a little bit hesitant to even point this out because like clearly epio52 knows their stuff super well
and i i could be wrong about this but if it's if i am if i'm not wrong about it then it's something
that could mess up a lot of people's testing which is that if you copy and paste epio52's payload
specifically um uh from the from the article there the template uh tag that i mentioned in the beginning
has an attribute called match and it's set to the value dock by default and it maybe it's something i
don't know about you know xpath stuff but this seems to to me that this should only apply to an
attribute called doc and lots of the other um uh you know payloads that i've i've looked up for this uh
xslt thing has a match equals slash in the template tag okay so that would be matching the root tag
of this whole xml document so it would always apply right um and so it could be that you may need to
modify this payload that's mentioned in uh epio52's um right up here or i could have something wrong so
if any of you guys know that's listening or feel like deep diving the uh the explanation definitely
let me know um if i'm if i'm off on this one but you may want to do your research before you just copy
and paste this payload which is good advice for any payload to be honest um but yeah in conclusion
super cool thing here if you're going to take anything uh if you want to do any xml deep diving
it could be really cool to look at extensible stylesheet language transforms uh and it also could
be good to look at transformations themselves um there's also a whole section of this referenced in
um on slide 26 of green dog's presentation that i mentioned before um where he's talking about all
sorts of different transformations that you can do uh and this is just such a cool thing because they're
processed before the actual um you know parsing of the signature so really really cool stuff there
definitely check that out okay i'm gonna take a sip of water and then we're gonna we're gonna close this
one out all righty so the last one that we wanted to talk about here uh that's on epio52's list is
if the target sp is serviced by an idp to which you have a legitimate account on a different sp serviced
by the same idp test whether or not the target sp accepts a valid assertion meant for the valid sp okay
so that was uh a lot of acronyms and stuff in there but the tldr of this is this is an attack called
token recipient confusion okay so let's say you have an account on app a that is serviced by the sso
provider right can you use the assertion from app a in the same response used to log into app a on app b
right so it's sort of like a like a token reuse sort of thing um and well really it's a token
recipient problem right a token because ideally the sp should be looking at the recipient field
of the subject confirmation data element uh which is a i'm reading this now which is a child of the
subject element in the saml response um to determine whether or not this uh saml assertion is is meant
for them right uh as opposed to some other recipient so if they're not validating this then you may be
able to do some weird stuff by um pulling a valid uh you know token to and and like we see this we
mentioned a sort of a similar thing um affecting tesla a couple weeks ago uh found by i want to say
it was evan um evan connelly um and it you know using this sort of idp you know taking a token from here
and using it over there that sort of thing right so it same sort of thing can happen with saml um with
this token recipient confusion uh bug here okay so that wraps up the attack vectors that i wanted to
cover under specifically saml related attacks um now i just wanted to close out this episode by uh
recovering some hacker one reports um and of course my my session died to hacker one so i'm gonna have to
like go ahead and put in my auth code right here um before i can load up the report because the report
that i'm gonna cover first is uh a report by yours truly um and it's an xss like i mentioned before
uh and so let's go ahead and take a look at that uh once i log in all right here we go so this was
this is a private program so i can't tell you who it is uh but it's a pretty textbook xss uh when it
comes to uh xss plus saml okay and so the situation was this there was a service provider or an app that
i wanted to log into and it was using saml so i took the saml response that i had from a valid login
and i modified some of the um attributes within that uh within that saml response values right and actually
i believe i was subbing every single url in there for my my callback server so that i could try to
find ssrf which is also not a bad idea um but uh one of the responses i got from that was a message from
the uh service provider saying hey uh invalid response uh the response was received at the
current url of the app instead of at the uh you know my callback url right and so uh and it was serving
that up in text html so i was like hmm i wonder if i can you know inject uh some some uh html characters
in there and so i went back and i modified and this is actually in the destination um attribute of the
saml response so he was checking that to confirm um you know who should be receiving this token kind
of like we talked about earlier with the um with the destination and the recipient stuff right so there's
multiple areas where you can check for that so i went to the destination attribute of the response
uh of the response tag which is the the parent tag and uh just sort of inserted a uh html encoded
payload because like i mentioned before sometimes you have to put html encoding inside of that that um
if you're putting it uh html control characters inside of an attribute in xml uh you have to encode
those with like ampersand less than uh or lt colon right or ampersand gt colon right um so we put those
in there and i submitted the the saml response back to the service provider and boom it reflected into the
uh into the response and i was able to get xss now when you get xss on a uh an app like this a lot of
times it will result in um account takeover because you can leverage that position uh in the saml flow
in the auth flow to hijack that um that page uh so and and hijack the user session so um very impactful
stuff here uh definitely be on the lookout for xss like i mentioned and then the last report that i
wanted to cover was the one login authentication bypass on wordpress sites reported by jolko a hacker
that reported this bug in may of 2016 to uber and this is just sort of a textbook off bypass via saml
right he found this newsroom.uber.com and it was using one login saml sso um i assume it's a plugin yeah
it is it's a plugin um and this report is is public so you can go see it it's report number one three
six one six nine that's one three six one six nine um and uh he he essentially just did what i mentioned
before which was he took a saml response and he you know sort of like a vanilla saml response and he
sent it to the that endpoint and then the endpoint was like yo bro you're missing this attribute and he's
like okay and so he puts in that attribute and then he's like yo you're missing this other attribute and
so he keeps on doing that until he fills out all the attributes that he needs and then it's like all
right cool got all the attributes log you right on in there's not even a signature tag in this whole
payload that he mentions here okay um so this is a textbook example of the first type that we talked about
which is the assertion without a signature okay uh so definitely know that this does exist out there
uh and like i mentioned when organizations are using saml they have to you know there's so many
different apps that are using it to log into it right um and so there's got to be a bug somewhere
there's got to be uh so hopefully going you know using that methodology using that mentality you guys
will go out there and find some sample bugs if you do definitely dm me it'd be super cool to know
that you guys found some sample bugs because of this episode um so let me just do a quick review keep an
eye out for the xss's in any sort of saml environment uh because for some reason they're particularly
prevalent um there's the assertion without a signature the signature signature exclusion bug
which you just delete the signature tags from a uh a saml response there's the xml signature wrapping
bugs which there are eight of them um by placing the signature in different spots uh throughout the saml
response and trying to trick the application into getting to trust your assertion even though the
signature uh is not valid for it okay so there's there's that one there's um assertion check that
the assertion is coming from a trusted idp that's the signature faking bug um there's the re assertion
replay bug which is like kind of a bug but not really um that you could check for and if there is it
could indicate sort of a less strict saml implementation um there's xxc's inside of saml there's srf
inside of saml either by them hitting some sort of url from within the saml response directly
or by a parsing a maliciously edited x509 certificate and calling out to your server to uh to validate
the certificate and i think there's a couple other things not just the um not just the authority
information access extension there's a couple places where you can put the ssrf payload inside the x509
certificate so definitely check out that uh blog post that i'll have in the description um from the
github blog by michael stepankin um so there's the the ssrf and then there's uh the xslt uh vulnerabilities
inside of saml that we spent a lot of time talking about definitely research these super exciting stuff
here could really result in some crazy bugs um and then finally there's the uh token recipient confusion bug
which um you know it would be kind of a specific scenario you need to have this happen but if you
do it still could result in auth bypass so definitely definitely some really interesting bug types here
all right i think that's it hopefully you guys have learned some stuff about uh saml and and uh if you
yeah if you find anything like i said let me know hopefully you're feeling a little bit more
more confident going into your sample testing all right go find some bugs
you